hi I'm Kathy Hilton and I'm Kim Richards
and we are spelling the ET
spilling spilling you're killing are you
spilling my teeth
[Music]
[Applause]
question okay number one okay
what is the best part of having me as
your big sister one I just I love I look
up to you everything that you do too you
are by far you are coming to cry you're
my biggest supporter you're always
behind me and always encouraging me and
when I think I can't do something
I know you believe I can yep I love the
way we laugh together I love the way we
had fun together and uh I love our
relationship I'm super grateful I don't
think people realize how funny you are
I know nobody gets it
what is your most favorite thing
about me that you that you admire or and
that you don't I admire your strength no
matter what is going on in your life and
you've been through some really tough
times you really try to look at the
glass half full
and I admire that you always managed to
pick yourself up by the bootstraps put a
smile on your face and
and you're not a gossip that's really
nice thank you Kathy I love that I love
you I don't know if I really want to
know the answer to this but I am curious
because recently
I think after the last couple years
being home
alone basically I've never lived by
myself I've learned a lot about myself
and I've done a lot of work on me that I
don't think I would have done removing
blockages I did liquid light therapy I
worked with you know all kinds of Dr Joe
I did my my work on myself but I still
feel like
when it came time to leave the house I
was
I I I it's like sometimes my feet
wouldn't move I was kind of scared so I
didn't know how that how you felt about
that because I I've never been one to be
late I mean I've been a little late here
and there but I've been on time my heart
yeah that would be the one thing I think
the being late thing yeah I mean I can
be 10 15 minutes late
but but two hours is a bit much no
because it's what it is is it's
disrespectful of others other people's
time I did say to somebody one time when
I got there and I was two hours late and
I said I just I got it you're late and I
said you know what you're right and you
have every right to be upset and I would
be mad at me if I were you but for me
right now I'm just
made it
[Music]
who got into more trouble growing up oh
you you had a big problem with bringing
home stray animals and it all the time
it was you could laugh all you want but
you have no idea before Mom do you
remember one of the things that we used
to do and you never got caught but I I
always did what do you remember what it
was
picking flowers flower napping flowers
laughing
loves flowers I still love flowers you
get yours and then you'd say go I go out
of water you got away you bow now it's
your turn
it's your turn people be having dinner
in their window and I'd be like crawling
up I don't want to go like okay and I
grab them and I hear Kimmy Richards get
out of my yard or I'm calling your
mother but then we had the nerve enough
to go and knock on their door and try to
sell them to them
[Laughter]
what would you say is my biggest pet
peeve
eat cheese
when people get dressed like you know if
it's not you know you're you you have
your way of being very casual too but if
it's not the right way sometimes if
we're all dressed up I think that's a
little pet peeve so you can't wear that
like that you have to tuck this in or
something it's just that one time though
really when I thought the dress was too
short for a mini dress
for graduation at a Catholic girls
school
and it's your daughter graduating it was
I mean I love you so I would tell you
and I'm glad you did what is something
that you have never told anyone
um
I do have something but I just
um you know I will never tell okay
I have two secrets you do well I'm gonna
know them by the end of the day or are
you weird I'm getting away with this one
spoils their grandchildren more
you or me
I think we're both guilty of it
I I definitely
I mean I'm told when I get there you
didn't bring anything did you want to go
no I know your mom no more stuff okay
I finally looked at Huxley and I used to
talk you didn't print anything like oh
and I go like this
and he goes in the bag you know what I
really don't you don't Nikki and baron
Paris it's too early to see with her
baby yet but they don't want like all of
this
every day is Christmas
neither does my my daughter but neither
does Brooke anytime I bring them
something they have to give something
away
oh that's good
I love the relationship you have with
your kids I love the relationship I have
with mine I think that we're I think we
got that from Mom I love all your kids I
love all Kyle's kids
I just love them so much like I look at
them and if anybody's to hurt them I get
like what what you said I feel like it's
uh
that's that's Palm well that's family
she no not all families like I think Mom
really instilled that in US yes our kids
are like sisters and brothers they're
not those are not like peasants at all I
just think that Mom instilled us to be
grateful for what we have grateful for
who we are stick together after Mom
passes somebody said to us
you know who is the favorite
who is your mom's favorite
and I didn't want to say anything
because I knew I was I am and you you
didn't wait
you said I I was and I said you don't
really believe that do you and you know
what I think I fact that mom had each
one of us thinking
that we were her favorite
is the greatest
you miss her
they do too
I miss Daddy I miss both of them you
know I wonder And when they see us with
our grandkids I know and I think now I
know why Mom
loved our kids that's the thing that
drives me crazy is that they that you
know they miss that
but I don't think they're missing it I
hope not I think they're there I know I
feel that way I feel it so strong
sometimes and I'm like whoa
she told me before she passed give me
I'll be in every room wherever you are
oh my God I'm never gonna get a break is
there any like talents or things that
you like to do that we don't know about
like that I maybe haven't gotten to
learn yet maybe that you picked up along
the way
kind of sometimes thinking about
learning to paint
so that would be nice right I know
you've got a pen somewhere yeah what I'd
like you to do is draw you no I draw
something on the card and don't let me
see it
what is that what is it
it looks like a nude
what is it
will you only gave me a second you
rushed me but no no it's just supposed
to be one thing
just like well that's a good thing an
apple it was buying easy your mirror oh
my goodness but look it does look like
okay we have no it looks like a nude man
[Music]
wow what is it hummingbird very good
very good wow you're very good
I love you
I love you I know you
are always there for me and I'm always
here for you whatever it is
[Music]
thank you